foreign
[Music]
I ask first
there's nothing I wouldn't do for my
daughter
Mrs Michaels Mr reckles asked me to give
this to you
[Music]
sorry ma'am the building's closed my
husband works inside I'm trying to reach
him
I haven't heard from Owen in 24 hours
where's my dad
I don't know what is that
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I can't believe this is happening
your husband that's not who you think he
is why are you making him sound like
some criminal mastermind I may not know
why your father did what he did but I
know who he is he lied to me then he
disappeared and I want to know the truth
I'm telling you we'll find him
like you need to get out of there now
where did you get this tell me who sent
you go now
and her stepdaughter or an imminent
danger is there something you're not
telling me they need to stay together
foreign
[Music]